hey guys it's justine and i'm so excited
for today's video as a lot of you guys
know i am an editor and i absolutely
love to edit and i'm going to toot my
own editing horn because i'm really
really fast and over the past few years
there's some shortcut keys that i use to
make my editing even faster and more
efficient but first a huge thank you to
artless.io for sponsoring this portion
of this video my editing style is i'm
kind of already editing while we're
shooting a video and i have the thought
in my mind of what i kind of want the
finished product to look like i'm always
thinking about the music and that is one
of the most important parts i feel like
to any video yes obviously you need to
have good lighting you need to have good
audio but when you're actually putting
this together music can make such a huge
difference so i've been using artless.io
for the past couple of years actually
and they have so many incredible tracks
they have a lot of sound effects i'll
put a link in the description if you
guys do choose to sign up for an annual
subscription you'll get the first two
months free art lewis offers access to
unlimited downloads of over 22 000 songs
and 27 000 sound effects these are also
updated daily so there's always new
stuff being added you can choose a
subscription tier that fits your needs
there's the personal plan that is yearly
for 9.99 a month or monthly that's 14.99
a month there's also the unlimited plan
that covers everything from personal to
commercial projects i really like the
unlimited plan because even after your
subscription expires you'll still be
able to have access to all of those
songs that you've used in your projects
i really like the for you page because i
feel like artless.io knows me better
than most of my close friends because i
have spent so much time on this website
finding songs downloading curating
making playlists and finding the perfect
track for my projects you can search by
mood video theme genre instrument and
they also have a really cool spotlight
feature that will show you some of the
artless.io originals so if you're a
content creator and you think that you
can just get by by using royalty free
music yeah you can but being able to
have access to a high quality music
library really steps up the game this
will also help you avoid getting
copyright strikes because this is
directly linked to your youtube channel
so you won't have to worry about losing
any type of revenue or having your video
taken down because of copyright strikes
you guys can sign up now for artlist.io
using the link below in the description
for two months free when you sign up for
an annual plan thank you again to
artlist.io for sponsoring that portion
of this video so i've got final cut open
and now we're gonna go through some of
my favorite shortcut keys some of these
you may already know but some of them
you might be like wow i didn't know that
i could do that so first things first
i'm gonna get my project started create
a
new library so our library's created
then i drag and drop in my content there
may be other better ways to do this but
i basically make all of my folder
structure all ready and then i drag and
drop everything in that adds keywords
and it separates all of the content into
many little folders so everything is
already organized for me you guys might
not shoot on multiple cameras but we've
started shooting with three cameras now
for most of our unboxing stuff so using
the multi-cam feature in final cut has
been by far just a lifesaver all i have
to do is select those three cameras
click new multicam clip we'll name it
unboxing part one it will automatically
sync all of our multi-cam clips you guys
can see here all of the tracks
everything is all matched up and if you
want to reorder them so i like having my
main camera one
top two and the other third camera as
our three so let's start
a new project
this is our project now using command
and the bracket keys this is a really
quick way to cycle through things that
are already open so we're here in the
multicam and then i'm going to go back
to my unboxing the phone yo and here is
that multicam clip to bring footage into
the timeline i like to use the w key
that automatically will bring all of
that content down something else that i
like to do is if i'm at the end of a
clip i hit the arrow up button
that will take me to the start of the
clip i use this all the time now in
multicam i'm gonna be using command
shift seven and that'll show or hide our
multi-cam clip and as we scroll the
timeline you're gonna be able to see
those two clips but since we have three
cameras i'm gonna switch to our four
angle display and you'll be able to see
all of those right there and why i like
multicam is we're able to just make all
of these changes inside of there and it
won't affect anything else that's
happening in your main timeline so since
this
clip right here is upside down i'm going
to click on that center clip make sure
it's highlighted by clicking that little
computer screen right there now to get
to the transform tool if i don't have to
use the mouse i'm not going to you could
either click right here to activate it
or you can click shift t
and that will bring up the bounding box
now
i just do a quick little rotate you can
also go over here and use the transform
and rotate there but i just quickly do
it just like that and then to go back
command open bracket all right so we're
here in our main timeline i want to get
quickly back to the beginning
spacebar
is
our
friend this is a simple way to start and
stop playing now if i want to get to the
beginning i'm going to hit the arrow up
take us back to the beginning also
command plus and minus
lets us zoom in and out i also love
editing with the magic mouse because
this will let me scroll the timeline
very quickly and i use that way more
than i'd like to admit some other
shortcut keys that may be very helpful
for some of you this little area right
here is the select trim position range
selection blade zoom and hand out of
these i mostly use the blade and select
so i use the b
and then hit a for select delete delete
plus minus
show our timeline so when we're talking
about editing clips i will sometimes
also use the playhead to edit so if i
see that okay i started my project here
i'm going to hit command b
and that will automatically slice right
where i have the playhead and then i can
just delete
that first part now if i want to save
myself a step and not have to delete i
will just go to where i want the first
cut to be and then i will hit option
open bracket that will automatically
make your cut and it'll also delete
whatever is before the cut you can also
delete whatever is after it by doing the
same thing but hitting option and close
bracket so as you see that cut was
perfectly made everything else was
deleted and of course command z
we should all know that one that's undo
i edit a lot with waveforms so when i'm
talking in an everyday conversation
there's a lot of times where i'll start
pausing because i'm so used to talking
like that when i'm editing where i know
i want to make cuts so if you see here
i'm talking so i'm going to hit
command b to blade it's and then i'll
just do this and this cut out some
spaces
so i kind of automatically already know
where i want this edit to be and another
thing is because this is a multicam
timeline i have the ability to watch
this play through
and i can click
to
to switch cameras i can click three to
switch to the third camera click back to
one and i'm basically editing this video
live it's like live switching and it is
by far the coolest thing ever now this
is something that final cut added
in a few updates ago and it has
absolutely changed my life because i am
super obsessive when it comes to audio i
hate when there's audio pops more than
anything so if you want to click here
into your audio this will expand the
audio so this is what i used to do i
used to go in here i would drag each
corner like that because that will give
you a nice audio fade drag it in
i would go over here do the same thing
to this and i would also do that to the
one above it
and it was so
freaking tedious drove me crazy but now
we have the best shortcut key in the
entirety of final cut so to use this
auto fader super simple you just select
a few of the clips that you want the
audio to automatically fade and you
click option
t
it is
the best so you'll see
here if we zoom in you can see that
slight little audio fade
on all of those pieces
i love it so much thank you final cut
for changing my life and saving me hours
and hours of time over the course of
years of editing another shortcut that i
find myself using quite a bit is command
6 this brings up our color board now
again
in the multi-cam clip this is great
because i can adjust the color and this
will affect everything in my main
timeline so we're going to
command six this is already there so
we're gonna bring down a little of that
a little of this and we're gonna hit
command seven to bring up our color
scopes here
i love adding a little extra saturation
it's just my style and then i sometimes
like to make my videos a little bit
cooler so we'll change
a couple little variables here
i also like to just copy and paste the
attributes to other pieces of my
timeline
so if i want to match this color to
another shot i'm going to hit command c
make sure this is selected and then
we're going to go down here
to this third camera and i'm going to
hit shift command v and this will bring
up this paste attributes now i like
doing the paste attributes because i
want to make sure that i'm only pasting
the color board because sometimes
there'll be some audio attributes that
are on sometimes they'll be a transform
or a crop and for this i just want the
color and this is most important for
something like this because i've already
changed this transform to be rotated so
if i did an option command v this will
paste the attributes and nothing will
pop up to give me an alert that happens
so watch what happens
so that flips around because it's
pasting the attributes from the previous
clip which was not rotated so now i have
to go and re-rotate that so to alleviate
things like that happening that's why i
like using the shift command v this pops
up lets me just make sure everything is
right and we're good to go so to clear
that we're gonna hit command seven now
shift command seven i know
similar but different brings back up our
multi-cam clips so i like having the
index open because i like my starting
point timeline to not start all the way
over to the end because i feel like
that's so far over and i like having it
right here with a little bit more of a
buffer so this is sort of how i edit is
i'll zoom in
kind of do
one of those
add a blade there maybe do this this
this
and then i'll command
click
click to select both of those and then i
delete them and then i kind of do a
little command t
great that sounds good love that most of
the time i will do a super rough edit by
playing it in double triple speed so
i will hit play in 1080 30 60. oh
actually something that since i'm now
listening to the audio
we have an audio problem so opening back
up shift command 7 this is very very
important because this drove me crazy
the first time that i ever started using
multicam clips so i'll start by clicking
here this enables video and audio
switching and i'll select the camera
that has the audio that i want to use
throughout the video
so that is
main
this over here was using a different
audio channel
it's dual 50 meg and that's now using my
log okay so now what i do is since this
one is selected i'll start at the
beginning of that clip and i make sure i
select this one
which will enable just video switching
so when i'm playing through
this dual 50 megapixel camera and i'm
switching my cameras because that will
shoot at
4k 30 and intent
all of that audio will stay the same now
a lot of times when i'm adding b-roll
over top of my footage this is a super
easy shortcut key that i like to use
because i don't want it to attach itself
to this timeline i don't want it to cut
into any of my footage i will find my
clip i'll play it i'll hit i
and then i will hit o for output and
then i will hit q
which will then
send it down to my timeline i then will
kind of adjust it just to see
how it looks great love that this is
another little shortcut that i use way
too often but it's super helpful instead
of trying to line this up perfectly to
something if i want to line it up right
to that mark yeah you can drag it you
can do all sorts of things but i like to
use just the little nudge tool here it
is the comma and period so you want to
make sure that you have your out point
selected
and then you'll just hit the period to
go forward and the comma
to go backwards you can also do this if
you have the whole clip selected you can
nudge the entire clip so you'll see that
whole clip is moving
as opposed to just the end point you can
also do it on the end point here as well
this is shot in 60 frames a second so
this will be a pretty great little
demo to show you how much i love using
this feature this lets you do a speed
ramp so you're going to go to where you
want the speed ramp or the speed slow
down de-ramp de-escalate down the hill
and you're gonna click shift b
and you're gonna see that this makes a
little mark right there and this gives
you
some speed options up here on the top so
this says normal so when you click on
this this will give you a drop down
you'll see 50 25 10
you can choose that if you want to slow
it down by 50 percent
great but you can also drag this
if you need that to fit a specific kind
of time frame so i do use that a lot so
if we want to kind of stretch this out
just to get to the rest of that clip you
can do that you can also make the speed
ramp
transition
slower faster by adjusting that right
there
and then if you want to kind of speed it
back up you just do the same thing shift
b and that'll give you another marker
so that middle part will stay slow
and then it speeds up again
this also gives you options here to kind
of just change it back to your normal
speed so that'll just kind of reset
everything so if i have done too many
speed ramps and i've messed up
everything and i just want to start over
i'll hit the speed back to normal and
we're good to go this is also a very fun
little trick the hold feature i use this
a lot of times when
i need to get a still shot so we'll go
to where i want to hold the frame we use
this a lot for specs hit shift h and
this gives you a static shot right there
and you could extend this
to as long as you need so depending upon
how you like to edit i like editing with
kind of small waveforms because a lot of
times in some of my projects i have tons
of layers so i need to be able to see
everything but if you don't have that
many things open you can decide how you
want your layout to be so you can kind
of make this a little bit larger you can
choose from some of their presets here
my favorite is editing probably just
like this so sometimes for b-roll i like
to use the teeth so if we hit t this
will let you trim but it's more of kind
of like a slip tool so it kind of lets
you move this footage around in that
time frame which i like because if you
already have this designated set piece
of time if you're putting a piece of
b-roll over it you might want it to
start a little bit further this will
give you that ability to just move it
around
and
there you go so like i was saying in the
beginning of this video that i am
obsessed with making sure that i have a
lot of music now normally when i edit i
do like to start out choosing the music
so now i'm going to drop in a few songs
so we're going to drop those in there
and then i do kind of like making a
little keyword collection by hitting
command k and i like doing music and
that brings up our little music section
so those will automatically be sorted
into music as you can see everything is
there so we've got our music in there
i'm going to drag and drop this in it
depends on the type of video i will
sometimes edit with the music to kind of
get the feel but a lot of times i will
just do one super quick rough edit of an
unboxing and then add the music in later
to make sure i have the timing but a lot
of times my favorite way to edit is
editing start to finish like if i get to
the finish line the end of that video it
is completely done you can also make
micro adjustments to audio which i love
using this i could used to use the touch
bar on the macbook to adjust on my audio
and since there hasn't been one i had to
figure out another shortcut key so i
like to use control minus
to give your audio a little nudge
and then you can just obviously like
adjust it like this too there's so many
different ways to adjust audio the
nothing bone has nice nice nice let's
fade it in i'll even adjust the audio as
it's playing 900 led lights that have
different patterns
that sounds good and then to adjust the
audio if you want to turn it up you hit
option and click in the middle of the
line
and then i just do a little one of those
and then you can raise this up in
between sources
nice sometimes also when i'm editing
with music i will actually go in
and i will add a marker on the audio
we're kind of like the beat drops so i
know if i'm editing i've got something
to like work up to so where's that beat
where's that beat when's it gonna drop
now it's going too fast
also v will hide real quick hear what
this sounds like
mark there it is
[Music]
[Applause]
and we've got all of our markers in and
i know to edit
just like that so now that our video is
well for the sake of this video it's
done wow it's beautiful i love it so to
export i always use compressor i
absolutely love it so i go to send a
compressor new batch and it brings up
compressor which is a separate program
from final cut and i will just export a
4k version
start batch there we go it's exporting
then i upload it make a thumbnail and
that's it the job here's done
well thank you guys so much for watching
i feel like this was a lot really really
quick if you guys have any questions
please leave them in the comments below
i also would love to hear from you if
you're a final cut editor what is your
favorite shortcut or tip or trick that i
might not know if you guys haven't
already please subscribe to my youtube
channel i look forward to seeing you in
my next video bye